bonjour jérémy stuff merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl ans alors avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet quelle est
la situation sanitaire en ce moment au
royaume uni et bien comme vous le savez
déjà le programme de vaccination se
déroule très très très bien les
dernières données montrent que la
vaccination réduit la transmissibilité
du virus en ce moment et le gouvernement
a même rapproché le son ça date limite
pour vacciner avec au moins une
une première dos tous les adultes de
plus de 50 ans donc il y à un certain
optimisme
est ce que les britanniques attend
justement des annonces du premier
ministre
cet après-midi les les citoyens et un
certain nombre de dogmes politiques
conservateurs demandent depuis un
certain temps un implant de
déconfinement parce que comme les
mesures de confinement sont plus
strictes aux et munich par exemple en
france
les gens ont besoin de perspectives
positives en même temps il est très
difficile d'avoir un plan de
déconfinement dans une certaine
incertitude donc l'annnonce de
collections sont aujourd'hui est là pour
créer une perspective qui va s'étaler
sur plusieurs mois
en quatre phases tri yann en ce moment à
ce jour 1 17 million de personnes ont
reçu une première dose du vaccin en
grande bretagne c'était une promesse du
premier ministre
est ce que est ce qu'elle va être tenu
cette promesse oui oui comme je les dis
le gouvernement avait d'abord fixé comme
objectif de vacciner tous les adultes au
mois de septembre
maintenant il a fixé la date du 15
juillet pour vacciner tous les adultes
donc on a en quelque sorte le vent on
touche du bois
en france on a ce débat sur sur le
vaccin faut-il se faire vacciner ou pas
est-ce que c'est la même chose au
royaume uni 1° beaucoup moins les
britanniques sont beaucoup moins rétifs
vaccination que les français et c'est un
avantage considérable et comment vous
expliquer justement cette attitude des
britanniques par rapport à celle des
français
difficile difficile c'est dans la
culture la vaccination dans la culture
et les lecteurs et un peu complotistes
des des gens qui sont contre la
vaccination ne circule pas autant ne
prennent pas les gens ont bien
l'habitude de la vaccination donc ça
leur paraît moins risqué on disait tout
à l'heure boris johnson va sortir un
plan de 2
deux sorties de confinement dans les
heures qui viennent
quel et l'humeur en ce moment au royaume
uni et par rapport à cette épidémie de
kobe 19 est-ce qu'on est plutôt
optimiste sur l'avenir à court et moyen
terme
il y à un certain optimisme bien sûr
tempéré par en même temps la crainte
d'un nouveau reconfirme ans donc tout le
monde cherche une nouvelle liberté mais
en même temps personne ne veut un autre
confinement tout de suite
donc on y va petit à petit et le plan de
boris johnson va être vraiment morcelé
en petit état et il aura quatre critères
pour valider la continuation du
programme donc c'est vraiment petit à
petit merci beaucoup jérémy staff
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france rappelle que vous êtes
représentant du parti conservateur
britannique merci beaucoup